I don't know why I can't do this
hairstyle where they put there's cute
little they put stuff in bobby pins and
it's cute and everybody else looks cute
and I look like a freaking polygamist
Christine Brown might have said bye bye
to the polygamous lifestyle but jokes
she still thinks she looks the part I
firmly believe plague me was what I was
supposed to do but living my life every
day day to day I would say it's so much
better I like my life so much better now
on Thursday the Sister Wives star posted
this clip to her insta story trying out
a new hairstyle but resulting in a bit
of a letdown I don't know why I can't do
this hairstyle where they put there's
cute little they put stuff in bobby pins
and it's cute and everybody else looks
cute and I look like a freaking
polygamist it's anger making it's
ridiculous of course Christine is a
former polygamist who gave up the
religious practices and plural marriage
in 2021 when she split from her now ex
Cody Brown now no target it's difficult
but I work hopefully going to be fine
right now I'm requiring a bit of a
distance I'm just starting to get to
know me I really like me and I want to
keep it that way no we're not going to
get any closer at all their messy
breakup was documented on season 17 of
the family's TLC reality show you never
tried to have really good relationship
with these other people
and that's the reason I'm pissed off
that's not true it's just I did man just
the knife in the kidneys over all these
years now Christine says she's down for
a monogamous relationship and in October
she told ET that while she's currently
single she has been dating I'm dating
just for fun just keeping everything
super light because that's just who I am
right now nothing serious just very very
casually following her split from Cody
Christine moved to Utah to be closer to
some of her children and her parents and
while Christine isn't with Cody anymore
she's still filming Sister Wives you're
not going anywhere in terms of Sister
Wives the television show absolutely not
I will stay with Sister Wives as long as
we have the show just to be fair it's
what our family's been doing for so long
I feel like it would be disloyal if I
decided to not be part of the show in
fact she recently showed off her new set
at home in Utah here it is the set
so there we go it has unfinished walls
and then the cameraman sit back in that
closet right there and all that came
after saying goodbye to the place she
filmed for years in Arizona so that's
the side where can we keep our clothes
and this is where the crew sits and this
has been
where I have sat for years talking about
my feelings and this is the last time
and it's a little bittersweet today so a
lot has changed for Christine but one
thing's for sure she still has a great
sense of humor everybody else looks cute
and I look like a freaking polygamist
foreign